abone ol
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
bu
ne kadar önceydi bir telefon geldi
Ankara Sanayi Bakanlığı Buyrun Asya
verimlilik organizasyon dini
organizasyon varmış Türkiye yeni üye
olmuş ü Welcome speech yapar mısınız
Yani Hoş geldin konuşması yapar mısınız
büyük zeka tabii ki ama konu ne dediler
ki tarım ve ziraat ben değilim torunu
anlamıyorum Bir yine resmim var ama
yapacağım Yok yok eder etrafımızı çok
ziraat mühendisi var Bize biraz farklı
bir şeyler lazım yani dijital Dünya ile
çağımızın dijital dünyasıyla bildiğiniz
komisyona tarımı birleştirecek bir
şeyler üzerinde yapabilir misiniz
deyince dedim ki Tamam tutam Benim Arzu
ettiğim konu Demez olsaydım ilk defa
insanlık tarihinde Muhtemelen Barbaros
Köyü olası ile Japonya ve Hindistan Zoom
yaptı bunu sadece bu sefer değil On Kez
yapmak zorunda kaldık çünkü Ben de
beğenmiyorlar the Neyse sonunda sonra
geldik sonumuzu yaptık işte 20 ülke Çin
Hindistan Japonya aklınıza ne geliyorsa
o ülkelerde falan filan arkasından
Geçenlerde tekrar bir telefon yine
Sanayi Bakanlığı Buse Japonya arıyor
dediler Evet buyurun dediler kitap
haline dönüştüreceğiz bir yıl boyunca
yapılan sunumları
introlar Aslında sizinkine Beğendik
Lütfen bunu yazıya döker misiniz ve
yazıya dökülecekti hikayeyi niye
anlattık bir defa telefon geldiğinde
yani Ülken için bir şeyler anlatır mısın
dediklerinde ve olabildiğince böyle
yenilikçi bir şey hani yeni refleks
türünden bir şey anlatır mısın
dediklerinde ne yapacağını bilemez
durumdaydım bir gün hayallerimiz vardı
Bir Gün heveslerimiz Vardı ama Derli
toplu değildi Esra diye bir arkadaşım
var O Ziraat Mühendisi Ben işin daha çok
bitler baytlar yani şimdi elektronik
kısmında Oysa Ziraat kısmında partnerlik
yapıyor da açıldı kase birazdan
anlatacağım Ah bir akşam uyandık Sonuçta
dedi ki biz geçmişin kadın bilgisiyle
yani Zaten birkaç yıldır üzerinde TEB
indiğimiz parmak kültür kavramıyla
çağımızın kadın geçti kalırız dediğimiz
dijital dünyasını birleştirebilir miyiz
öpüşebilir miyiz değiştirebilir miyiz
hemen dünya litre türlü aramaya başladık
bulamadık yoktu o Düşünsenize muhteşem
bir şey yok belki vardı Biz bulamadık Ne
fark eder ki hiç vermedik belki bulmak
istemedik Ama gerçekten baktık yoktu
Tamam Şahane Okey üzerine çalışıyoruz
Ozan dedik ve buna benzer bir şeyler
çıktı isim koymamız lazım da uydurduk
perma 1404
permakültürün gündür seslenişi Azra Abla
zaten 40 da işte hani her şeyi 4'tür var
ya artık İstanbul'a giden otobanı böyle
gidiyor değildi dikine çevirirsek Eğer
ve normal otoban kızımı bu 30440 larda
gidersek yaşamın yani bizler için
yaşamını anlamlı olduğu ilk atmosfer
katmanına ne kadar zamanda varıyoruz 130
da gidiyor onu yukarı dikine doğru
gidiyorum Gök ne kadar Evet yarım saat
Evet ben de ve saat sahnede bilirdimki
zannediyordum Hani her şeye düşünüyorum
o kadar büyüktü dünya o kadar büyük ki
ben ne kadar pislik yaparsam yapayım
kirletemem Çok küçük zannettiğimiz den
çok daha kadar bir alanda Yaşamaya
çalışıyoruz Dolayısıyla yeni reflekslere
kesinlikle ihtiyacımız var Hadi gelin
başlayalım tarım ana konumuz hepimiz
aynı noktaya gelmek için tarımın
tarihinden başlayalım isterseniz
tıkladım Toprak üstü toprak altı su üstü
Sualtı Hayvansal ve bitkisel her türlü
faaliyete tanımlıyoruz Tamam şöyle bir
hayal kurabilir miyiz Kendimiz için her
şeyden önce ama çocuğumuz
dünyadaki bütün canlılar ve en önemlisi
gezegenimiz için daha sağlıklı olmayan
bir gezegende bizim sağlıklı varlığımızı
sürdürmemiz İmkansız Bu biliyoruz En
azından biliyorsak öğrenmek zorundayız
okey Hadi bir hayal kurabilir miyiz
dedik ve parmakla 40 uydurduk yani Biraz
önce söylediğim gibi bi perma
Sürdürülebilir promont Sürdürülebilir
bir tarımı acaba çağımızda öpüştür
edebilir miyiz hikaye bu dostlarım
hepimizin bildiği gibi 12 bin yıl önce
yerleşik düzene geçtik hepimiz bunu şey
diye biliyorduk a İnsanoğlu akıllandı ne
güzel artık hayvanın peşinde koşmayı
bıraktı yerleşik düzene geçtim hiç de
öyle değilmiş yani insanın Fosiller
evrimi değil insanın negatif devriminden
bahsediyoruz ama konumuza değil geçelim
onu şimdi vb şu anda 7 buçuk milyar
civarında yız
sadece 30 sene içinde bu salondaki
herkes görecek Ben dair sadece 30 TL 10
milyar olacağız Biz her 3 bu yanına bir
kişi daha gelecek nasıl besleniriz
panelin ilk zamanları hatırlayın ilk
önce tuvalet kağıtlarını saldırdık
arkasına Makarnaya saldırdık doğru mu
Doğru aç kalmaktan koptuk ve çok
haklıydık ve bugüne korkmak zorundayız
sadece 30 yılda iki buçuk milyar Hun
daha geliyor Dostlar yeni refleksi
ihtiyacımız olduğu çok kısa zaman devam
edin Nasıl yapacağız bunu doğayı taklit
ederek Bunu ancak başarabiliriz Yani
bugün yaptığımızın tam tersini yaparak
bugün Biz kendimiz bir halt zannederek
milyonlarca yıl içinde oluşan düzeni
doğanın kendi kendine oluşturduğu ama
öğrenerek
oluşturduğu düzene sanki daha iyisini
biliyormuş casına davranıyoruz büyük
yanlış dolayısıyla taklit etmekten
korkmadan çekinmeden doğayı taklit etme
şartı içinde olmamız lazım arkası A101
Az önce basıldığı Biraz sonra geldik
alacağız çok erken başarıyı yakaladı Bu
süre niye takip etmeyeyim ya da doğayı
taklit ederken bir yandan da İmalat
Sanayi takip edebilirim Aslında Bunlar
İlla birbiriyle kavgalı konular olması
gerekmiyor Belki de ölçtükleri bir yer
var Onu keşfedebiliriz belki hep beraber
gibi
arkasında ise zaten dijital Çağ beyaz
dişler çağı olmadan hiçbir şey olmaz
panelinden bahsettik yeni bir teknoloji
ihtiyacımız var diyelim Ve arkasından
tabi olmazsa olmaz her ne yeni kavram
ortaya koyacaksak etik değerlere tamamen
bağlı etik değerlerin dışına çıkmayan
bir şeyler ortaya koymamız lazım diye
düşündük gelen permakültür nedir
bilmeyen arkadaşlarımızın hızlı hızlı
geçer üzerinden işte bir malsın bunların
işte kaç 1970'lerde Avustralya'da
Arkadaşlarıyla beraber ilk Fikri ortaya
atan kişi çok taze ne oldu Bu enerji
Yüksel değil mi çok taze en çok hızlı
dünyada yayılıyor Aslında söz söyledi
parmağına agricultural diye başlıyor
Hadise ancak zaman içinde evleniyor
Tanrı tutkal çınara dönüşüyor yani
sadece tarım değil tarım olmaktan çıkıp
aynı zamanda Yaptığımız her şeyin artık
Sürdürülebilir olması gerektiğini
1970'lerde söylüyor bir son 35 yıldır
dünyada Sürdürülebilir kavramı üzerinde
tek iniyoruz ihtiyacından fazla sahip
olduğunu her şey ahlaksızlıktır diyor bu
Muhtemelen hepimiz Ama burası güzel 3
felsefi yaklaşımı var yani her konuda
olması gerektiği gibi felsefi
yaklaşımlar da başlıyoruz gerekiyorsa
Eğer çok basit üç yaklaşım var bir
tanesi kör kir diğer Ruhumun kırdı yana
people curvefever şey yok yani diyor ki
her ne adım atmak istiyorsan her ne
yapmak istiyorsan ilk önce örtük Air
bu gezegenimi olan etkisi nedir Pozitif
nedir arkasında insanoğluna benzem sil
edilen canlılara hayvansal veya bitkisel
canlı olan etkisi nedir üçüncüsü de
artanı acil şekilde dağıt yani
permakültürün emrettiği Dünya çok
değişkenli çok Farklı şeylerin beraber
yaşadı hayvanın bitkinin cadının Dursun
insanın beraber yaşadığı bir dünyayı
tavsiye etmekten geçiyor parmak kültür
arkasından gelelim kendi hayatımıza
dükkanda hayatımıza hatırlayın Oo
hatırlayın deyince hatırlayın olacak 13
milyar yıl önce
[Kahkaha]
ben dedikleri şey oldu kaçıncı defa oldu
bilmiyoruz Neyse oldu arkasından işte
dört buçuk milyar yıl kadar önce
gezegenimiz oluştu ilk canlılar 3.8
milyar yıl kadar önce homolar yani
Bizler Üç iki buçuk milyon yıl önce
oluşu bu başladık Belki benim de halinde
önce cehaletin Evet ben şey diye
düşünürdük erektus var orman neandertal
var homasapiens var falan filan
birbirinin Deva mıymış gibi zannederdim
Ben en azından cehaletinden Meğer hepsi
aynı zamanda yaşamışlar Yani dünyada
birkaç değişik insan ırkı beraber
yaşamıştır ancak homasapiens sap sap yaz
bildiğiniz gibi hayatta kalmayı başaran
cins hayvan olmuş ve 70 bin yıl önce de
şu anda sahip olduğumuza yakın birisi
selka biletlerimizi
kazanmışız ve dediğimiz gibi 12 bin yıl
önce de yerleşik düzene geçip tarım
dediğiniz şeyi başlamışız 40 a
geldiğimizde
4074 sonra Hepimiz duyduk değil mi yani
bundan işte 2010'lu yılların başında
11'ler 12'ler de Almanya'da başlayan ve
ve endüstrinin dördüncü devrimi diye
adlandırılan bu hareketten bir
yaklaşımdan bahsediyoruz bir sanayi
devrimi neydi yani lise çağlarında
dinletmeye hatırlıyorum gerçekten
hatırlayabiliriz işte su buharı gelmişti
su buharı insan kas gücünü yerine geç
geçmişti Dolayısıyla endüstri çağı
başlamıştı ve makineler Çağ başlamıştı
bir sonradan bana bir sanayi devrimi
dedik arkadaşlar Yüzyıl geçmeden
Elektrik geldi elektrik motoru çevirdi
motor hattı çevirdi seri üretim
insanoğlunun Hayatında ilk kez devreye
girdi ve buna sonradan biz iki sanayi
devrimi dedik işte bunlar 1970'lerde
yine eş zamanlı elektronik devirde
elektronik devreye girecek yazılımıyla
donanımı ile otomasyon çağı başladı daha
önce yok otomasyon çağı 3. sana veririm
dedi ki dördüncü şu anda yaşamakta
olduğumuz değil mi sebze dijitalleşme
Peki
ama aq40 baktığımızda Peki onun
tarihçesinden nasıl tarifler
İndirebiliriz nasıl sınıflandırır bu
işte birincisi 12 bin yıl önce ama
çağımızın onbin yıl önce işlemi milattan
sonra 700 liraya kadar olan kısımda
yerleşik düzene geçmek yani
toplayıcılıktan yerleşik düzene giriyor
Ondan sonraki süreç ikinci devrimi 700d
1800 arasında orada da hatırlayın lise
bilgisi İpek Yolu Baharat Yolu gibidir
uzak Coğrafi bölgeler arasında tarımın
yani gıdanın Mehmet halinde satılmaya
başlanması yani komurcusu zation
diyebilir birisi yerleşik diğer ise
ticari bir dünyanın başlanması üçüncüsü
ise çok yeni
1800'lü yıllardan günümüze kadar olan
süreçte otomasyon yani traktörler
çatlaklıklar gibi mekanik devrimler ama
maalesef yanında aşağılık kimyasal
devrimlerde hepimizi her gün kanser eden
devreye 3. tarım Devri bu adına İlla
peruk olmak gerekirse Peki dördüncü
Devrim neyi ifade edecek ya şu
geçirdiğimiz tarım 4 sorun dünya
literatüründe kullanmasını 45 yıllık
geçmişi var Bunları beş sene önce
düşünmemiz çok zordu 10 sene önce
düşünemez bile nedir ki
3.8 milyar yıl boyunca İnsan canlıların
yaşadığı ve ya da iki buçuk milyar yıl
boyunca işte hooke'un hayatı hormonun
olduğu dönem olduğunda geçir son 3
beslendiği konuşuyoruz son mili saniye o
kadar yeni her şey aslında ama
muhtemelen geleceğiz bu Çok karmaşık
gibi görünen Teknoloji bu salon için
değil ama toplumun tamamı için karmaşık
gibi görünen teknoloji aslında hiç o
kadar karmaşık değiller yatarım da
başarıyla kısmen veya tamamen uygulamaya
başlandı bile ülkemiz dahil olmak üzere
peki burada ne görüyorsunuz ben
gözlerimle gördüm yıl o
lütfen tavuk yemeği Tıp ve bacakları
kırılıyor ve hemen
yiyen makinesine canlı canlı
gönderiyorlar Paramparça edip unufak
edilip yeme haline getiriliyor lar o
yerleri falan hikaye gerisini
biliyorsunuz anlatmama gerek yok Bize
her gün her saniye kanser eden şu anki
aşağı düzenlen bahsediyor yok bizim yeni
refleksleri ihtiyacımız var böyle
gidemez mümkün değil Hata yaptık
dönmemiz lazım Bayağı dairesi Dayı
kaybettik monokültür hale geldik
kirlettik hissettik her şeyim mahvettik
dersek işte yalan olmaz aslında değil mi
Ama bu
gündür Peki yarın
sunde koleksiyon yaşına tanımıyorsun
bitter başlar kısmına geliyoruz çok
değişik yöntemlerle detaylarına girmeden
uydularla şunlarla bunlarla dur onlarla
şunlarla bunlarla Ben araziyi sürekli
olarak gözlemleyebilir sen sürekli
olarak oradan geri toplayabilir Sen
havanın rüzgarın güneşin o rutubetin
sıcaklığın parametrenin sürekli olarak
Birlikte koleksiyon yani Bey toplama
yöntemiyle toplayabilir sen ve bunları
topladıktan sonra
gelecek sütü de görüyorsunuz Bu arada
tarımın unutmadan tarımın geleceğin en
stratejik konusu olma ihtimali çok
yüksek pandoni bize buna çok net
gösterdi çiftçiliğin bugün tukaka
ettiğimiz yani ara Allah'ın ineği Allah
tesiri Allah kötüsü konusu dediğimiz
dünyada pandemic 2 çok yakın ilişkimiz
var birbirimizi seviyoruz çok seviyeli
bir ilişkimiz zaten diliyle bu
sebeplerden onun sayesinde tarım layık
olduğu prestiji ne tekrar geri kazanma
yolunda ve en de projesi sayesinde
distal Yani karar noktasına
getirebiliyoruz yazılarınız o kadar
gelişti geçmiş olmadığı kadar iyi
çalışan yazılımlar ilk bu sahibiz artık
geçmiş olmadığından daha iyi Dolayısıyla
topladığımız belki Yani birileri
sıfırları doğrudan Buluta gönderip
bulutta işleyip çiftçiye kadar destek
desteği olarak bilgi olarak ve detaylı
bilgi olarak gönderme şansına sahipsin
ve keza
Çağ aplikasyonlar artık oradan elde
ettiğimiz bilgileri Bu uygulamalar
olarak kullanabilir hale geleceğiz
bunlar bunlar hiç mesela af değil
hiçbirisi laf değil bakın gelecek
şirketini görüyorsunuz geleceğin demek
bile doğru değil hasta Bugün ütüsünü
görüyoruz Google niye gras projeleriyle
gözlük projeler ile uğraşıyor Çünkü
burası gelecek yani çok iyi eğitim almış
Şehirliler doğaya köylerine aynı benim
yaptığım gibi doğaya köylerine
döndüklerinde
geleceğin tarlalarını bu şekilde
çiftlikleri bu şekilde yönetiyor
olacaktı endüstri40 da zaten insana
ortadan kaldırmaya geliyor işte
geleceğin çiftçisi ve bu kararlarla
yeteri kadar kaynakları çok daha doğru
kullanarak hem gezegene Hem canlı hem
insanlara hemde büyüklerimiz
çocuklarımızı her şeyi daha büyük katkı
sağlayacak diyelim Peki sonra geliyoruz
diyeceksiniz ki ağabey ağabey bunlar
Batur yapar Batur yapsın biz 10 sene
sonra öğreniriz biz de yaparız falan
Hayır bakın burada kötü bir çekim ama
olsunlar önemli değil 40 gerçekten
lâyıkıyla uygulayan bir çiftliğimiz in
çok kısa bir videosunu gördüğünüz Yani
bütün çiftliğe bir insan sörler
yerleştirilmiş durumda real-time Eğer
gerçek zamanı yani anlık öyle saat başı
falan değil anlık olarak 80 türlü
parametreyi ölçüyor şifre sistemine
Buluta gönderiyor falan filan bundan
Birkaç yıl önce Tanrım 40 dediğimizde
yani tarafında işler sizi konuş
konuştuğumuzda maalesef ekosistem sonda
zayıftı ama o kadar hızlı gelişti ki ve
o kadar pırlanta gençlerimiz bu konuya
el attılar ki şaşırırsınız yani ücretsiz
11'li adam üste iki tane pırlanta
gencimizi gördük şehirde adam veya kız
Çoğu kız vardı geliyorlar tarım 40 cılık
oynamaya başlıyorlar yani dijital sarı
oynamaya başlıyorlar şu anda 150 geçti
yani Start düzeyleri yaslar topun
gelişmişi düzeyinde Finans sorular işte
ne bileyim benim gibi Melek yatırımcılar
Ondan sonra veren çok yaptılar şunları
bunları saydığımızda şu anda ülkemizde
150 geçti ben bunu söylerken Muhtemelen
160 geçiyoruz şu anda dijital tarım
üzerine tarım 40 üzerine uğraşan
gençlerimizin hayatta benim gibi
gençlerin sayısı Dostlarım
ve bütün dünya bu konuyu Sadece dört beş
senedir konuşuyor İnanılmaz bir şekilde
Dünya ile eşzamanlı yız ve iki tane
gencimiz bir birisi Duygu mu İşte
onların Barbaros köydeki yerimize geldi
Duygu dedim Sen ne yapıyorsun dedi ki
duydu işte ben Star topum var peki
Şahane birazcık anlattı arkası din kız
dedim Sen çok ciddi iş başarmışsın
sadece birkaç sene sonra evet yaparsın 3
milyon doları cebine koyarsın dedim
Sen hayırdır geçen sene geldiler dedim
ben çok kötüyüm geldi dedi bir
değerlendirme yaptılar dedi 30 milyon
dolar dedi
Duygu 33 yaşında Tunceli'nin dağ
köylerinden yani boğazın yollarından
değil bakın öylesine muhteşem bir ülkede
yaşıyoruz ki böylesine muhteşem bir
coğrafyadayız
Kia dikili alanların anlamında
Avrupa'nın ikincisi büyüklüğün deyiz
inanılmaz mü mi topraklarımız var yani
yok etlerimiz haricinde yaş ekmek de
için yani ortağı yaşayan 78'e doğru
gidip gidiyor Yani aslında yaşlanıyoruz
ama diğer taraftan ortağına yaşımızı 31
yani muhteşem bir gençliğe sahibiz ve
dört mevsimi aynı anda yaşayabiliyoruz
Dolayısıyla geleceğim bu en sıkıcı
konusunda tarım konusunda inanılmaz
yüksek potansiyelli bir coğrafyadayız
permakültür dedik purmo kültürle ilk
başladığımızda atladım onu mutlaka
söylemen lazım mı Ben yarın ve bugün
bize kakalama ya çalışılan o aşağılık
yaklaşımların tamamını yapmadık veya
tersini yaptık dediler ki toprak
patlayacaksın Banu kurmadın dokunmadı
bile toprağı gün permakültür izin
vermiyor arkasına dediler ki
çarpılacaksın topladıktan çıkacaksın
tırmıklama dık dediler ki güleceksin
gübreleme dik dediler ki ilaç zehir
vereceksin vermedi Ama şunu seven
sonunda ikisi başarılı olduk peki sonra
ne yapabiliriz eksi
carbon-carbon kimler duydu
Peki sıfır karbon hepimiz biliyoruz
sonra gerek yok değil mi lan sıfır
emisyon öylesine yaşam alanları yarat ki
bu ev alabilir çıktık olabilir işyeri
olabilir fabrika olabilir Tamam
60S olan emisyon 0ol ya da hangi çalışıp
teknoloji şirketinde 2020/3 yılında
cumhuriyetimizin 100'üncü yılında
Türkiye'nin ilk sıfır emisyonlu
fabrikasını yapalım ve beslenmiş tik Ben
artık ayrı mi Evet arkadaşlarım eminim
Aynı yolda gidiyorlar şurada bir iki
yıldız kaldı Türkiye'nin ilk eksi karbon
Çiftliği yapmak gibi bir hedefimiz var
var güneşin fotoğrafı güneşin ısısı
Rüzgar topraktan hit Bank ve Biyogaz
teknolojileri kullanarak elde ettiğimiz
yenilebilir elektrik enerjisini şebekeye
Daha doğrusu gezegenimize bastığımız
taktırdı o kadar fosil kaynağı
kullanılmasını engelleyeceğim iz için
gezegene diyeceğim ki sana bile borcum
yok